the microphone was placed on taylor
hearn during batting practice here's
what he had to say
but i don't have ketchup on my face i
ate a burger earlier
you think i could beat trevino running
backwards
he definitely runs a little slow i think
his son josiah could beat him in a race
oh
somebody's cut out got knocked out
they're down for the count back there
jose trevino can throw anybody out in
the major leagues right-handed but
left-handed he couldn't throw a toddler
out
you heard it first here we'll see lance
mccullers on the bump for the houston
astros he has one start against the
texas rangers this season it was a
couple of starts to go back in minute
maid park arguably his best start of the
season when he went seven innings
gets a strike out of tavares to start
off this game with an elevated fastball
[Applause]
swing and a miss there's the cutter up
how about lance he's picking up
strikeout through the new pitch well
kyle gibson will pitch for the rangers
this will be his 12th start his best
start was two starts ago in houston when
he shut the astros out here comes gibson
swinging and a miss he struck him out on
a slide first strike after cal gibson
the astros failed to score they had two
hits and they left one middle of the
second nothing nothing
and mccullers continues to own gallo
that's now eight strikeouts in his last
nine appearances as gallo goes down
swinging excuse me andrews has been
bothered by a back injury as lance picks
up a strikeout the throw down to second
doesn't matter swinging strike for tajed
for the final out of the inning
and a called third strike at the top of
the zone three pitch strikeout for
mccullers who has five strikeouts first
time through the lineup went away in the
third
there it is called third strike tavares
may have had that plate expanded a
little bit on that one but it works for
lance for strikeout number six calhoun's
had a tough time making contact against
lance in his career he's over six with
four strikeouts
that one bounces in there and trying to
head the second base is guzman and he is
out dustin garneau recovers quickly to
throw out goosebumps for the final out
[Applause]
here's a swing and a miss by guriel
so he strikes out on that kyle gibson
slider kyle recording his second
strikeout of the evening
it's got a couple of strikeouts on the
cutter in the first inning including
willie calhoun
and there it is again lance picks up his
third strikeout with that cutter
picks up strikeout number seven
swing and a miss so much for that
i thought it was going to go strikeout
ground out strikeout but he picks up two
strikeouts ties a season high
two out single then a walk needs to lock
down and make a pitch right here
swinging a miss he got outdoors swinging
lance ends up with three strikeouts in
the inning and he works around a couple
of base runners
it's official chuck has worked three
thousand consecutive
games hope chuck was looking down on the
field because all the players were on
the top step of the dugout from both
teams
looking his way and clapping
that was beautiful
gibson's 1-2
and a strikeout of bregman gets us going
here in the sixth inning
there's a strikeout of toro
and there are two lines
[Applause]
gallow shoots this one out into right
field second hit in the inning for the
rangers
a couple of base runners now
all right solax had a good night
with the base hit in the walk
this ball on the ground and into left
field that's a base hit around third
base calhoun here comes the throw not in
time
solac drives in the run and makes it
one-nothing rangers percentage is
unheard of
and that's why i mean chasing ball four
and then swinging through and strikeout
that'll do it for the rangers they take
the lead with three singles
diaz solves herget with a base hit down
the right field line oledmiss is gonna
head to second as joey gallo makes the
play a little bit late
led miss diaz a lead off base runner for
the astros here in the seventh
here's jack mayfield and he hits the
ball well this is to center field
tagging up at third is diaz eod tavares
throw is going to be late i think yeah
he has just barely got across in time
that'll tie the game up at one appease
on the line drive sack fly by jack
mayfield
he likes pitch and this one in the air
out to left field tucker was shallow
he's racing way back way back gone
mathis leads the yard a three run shot
and he's opened things up for the
rangers in the seventh inning it's four
to one
well he knocks belak out of the ball
game and that smiles all the way around
guys on the bench are happy for him and
he's thrilled too how about this next
pitch into right field into bleachers
tavares
goes yard off scrub
and the rangers
flexing a little bit in the seventh man
i couldn't even get the words out but
coyotes had the ball halfway out of the
ballpark
five hits in the inning for the rangers
a couple of home runs this one out to
right field that's a base hit it'll get
home at least one run solac into third
base they'll hold him
odor adds to the rangers lead it's six
to one
that's shaping up to be the rangers best
ending of the year
[Applause]
fly ball down into that left field
corner back there forward solace what a
catch up against the wall
wow got twisted backward who made a
great leaping grab at the wall to take
back a home run and finish the win over
houston